e Senti devo acquistare un nuovo
telefono per Maria de live della mia
bambina Quanti anni ha la sua bimba ne
sa 18 luglio Ah e come vorrebbe che
fosse Ma guardi non posso lamentarmi
perché è bellissima preso da me
ovviamente ecco forse se studiasse un
po' di più Sarebbe meglio e no Signore
Intendevo come vorrebbe che fosse il
telefono Oddio scusi per il
misunderstanding Allora sicuramente deve
fare delle belle foto dei video mia
figlia va sempre concerti e io mi
chiedono a guardarli adesso invece
stanno lì a registrare col telefonino Ma
magari non se li godono neanche io le
proporrei Honor 70 che è un'eccezionali
doppia fotocamera principale e la prima
modalità solo CAP del settore e che
sarebbe scusi che cantanti piacciono a
sua figlia ma adesso sei fissa con
questi maneskin Ecco quel Damiano mi
sembra rischiare così con la modalità
solo capo quando suo figlio andrà al
concerto dei maneskin potrai
Visualizzare un video di tutto il palco
e può selezionare una persona per
esempio Damiano e creare un video che
mette in risalto solo lui proprio come
ho fatto con lei sente non posso usare
anch'io il concerto di Baglioni Quindi
se magari glielo presta Sì tesorino Ti
sto comprando il telefono Sì è davvero
una sciccheria Eh no mi chiedi tipo
magari ogni tanto così se ti fa eh
potresti prestare almeno per caso dici
di no Perfetto tesoro tranquilla che si
gli ingredienti meno di due